bonsoir à tous voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce dimanche
un cyclone s'est abattu sur la birmanie
des gens dépassant les 200 km heure ont
dévasté l'ouest du pays la ville de
rangoun a été touché le bilan est de
plusieurs centaines de morts
il y un dans la france s'apprêtait à
élire nicolas sarkozy ya un an après
c'est l'heure des premiers bilans
ce soir nous reviendrons sur un élément
de la rupture qu'il souhaitait le style
ou plutôt les style de présidence
adoptée par le chef de l'état le beau
temps le soleil les vacances
et puis l'heure des retours sur les
routes de france des retours difficiles
ce soir aux abords de la capitale mais
également dans la vallée du rhône
nous ferons le point dans un instant le
grand format de ce dimanche c'est un
témoignage celui de lydia bouleversé par
la sphère fritzl en autriche
cette française a choisi raconter son
propre calvaire
une femme terrorisée par son père
pendant 28 ans enfin du football et
match de la peur vont se poursuivre
jusqu'au bout pour toulouse lens et
paris chacun craint une descente en
ligue 2 nous verrons ce soir quelle
serait et conséquences pour un club
comme le paris saint-germain de quitter
l'élite du football français
voilà pour les titres merci d'être avec
nous et on commence par la birmanie le
bilan ce soir n'est que provisoire mais
il est déjà de 350 victimes
c'est la conséquence du cyclone qui a
traversé cinq régions du pays la plus
grande ville
rangoon a été fortement touché les vents
je vous le disais on atteint plus de 200
kilomètres heure sophie rodier en 48
heures le cyclone nargis ça tout dévasté
sur son passage sous un déluge
les vents ont soufflé jusqu'à 240
km/heure ici les habitants abandonnent
leur maison détruite quelques vêtements
récupérés à la hâte dans certains
quartiers de rangoon la capitale
économique plus d'électricité plus de
transport et plus d'eau potable
les militaires déblaient les routes mais
des témoins déplorent la lenteur des
secours
sur ces images de la télévision d'état
birmane n'apparaît aucune victime mais
plusieurs centaines de personnes
auraient trouvé la mort le premier
ministre birman qui quitte rarement son
palais tente de rassurer les sinistrés
les sans abri se compteraient par
dizaines de milliers même s'il est
impossible de connaître la réelle
ampleur des dégâts
les communications sont coupées les
nations unies ont proposé leur aide
mais pour l'instant la junte militaire
birmane ne l'a pas acceptée au chili
c'est un volcan qui inquiètent toujours
une partie de la population plus de 4000
habitants de la zone sud du pays ont dû
abandonner leurs habitations
est-ce qui est comme souvent
impressionnants dans ce type d'éruption
c'est la luminosité les cendres et les
péniches qui se sont mis en place sur la
région riche harbin et le réveil d'un
géant après un sommeil de 9000 ans le
vieux volcan s'est remise à gronder ces
premières images aériennes montrent avec
précision le cratère qui s'est ouvert en
son sommet d'où s'échappe un panache de
fumée blanche de plusieurs centaines de
mètres de haut
au pied du volcan la ville de shenzhen
donne l'image d'une bourgade enneigées
un manteau de cendres a recouvert la
région dans un rayon de 20 km les
autorités ont distribué des masques
l'eau potable est amenés par camion
les évacuations par la mer le chemin le
plus sûr se poursuivre
hier c'était les femmes et les enfants
aujourd'hui ce sont les hommes mais dans
les campagnes les secours tardent à
arriver le gouvernement s'occupe des
gens désirent mais pas des paysans nous
sommes désolés nous ne savons pas si
nous serons évacués de main ou un autre
jour en fait nous savons rien
je suis d'ici et je mourrai ici qu'est
ce que je pourrais faire d'autre
j'ai mon travail c'est ici chez moi à
terme 7000 personnes devraient quitter
la région
les autorités reconnaissent ne pas
savoir quand les évacués pourront
rejoindre leur foyer
si le retrouve un jour tout dépend des
humeurs du volcan dont les sismologues
prévoit une éruption imminente
en france il a une nouvelle fois fait
beau aujourd'hui sur une grande partie
du pays mise il a fallu reprendre pour
beaucoup le chemin du retour en fin de
week-end prolongé ou fin de vacances
avec pour conséquences de nombreux
ralentissements dans la vallée du rhône
près de bordeaux en normandie ou encore
en nile de france ont fait le point ce
soir avec edouard baer jan et sébastien
laffargue les retours de vacances et de
week end prolongé sont parfois bien long
à 18 heures on comptait 200 kilomètres
de bouchons sur l'ensemble du réseau
routier point critique
le péage de saint-arnoult sur l'a10 pour
rejoindre la capitale 60 km de
ralentissements 20 minutes on a fait
trois kilomètres pas beaucoup c'est les
jours du retour en région parisienne
avec des bouchons traditionnels
en province le trafic est dense dans la
vallée du rhône et au retour de
normandie 26 km de bouchons à pont
l'évêque
mais dans l'ensemble on circule plutôt
bien car ce week-end
dallier de la gendarmerie pour
fluidifier la circulation c'est le
soleil les aires d'autoroutes sont aussi
bondée que les plages pas forcément du
goût de tous la route colas routes quoi
raccroche alors en plus cela qui est
revenue s'ignorent quoi 29 degrés sur le
sable c'est beaucoup plus paisible sur
la plage du touquet qui a sorti ses plus
beaux de pièces et les dragueurs qui
vont avec la personne habilitée
les estivants en profiter jusqu'au bout
de ce premier soleil de mai en espérant
le week-end prochain aussi chaud la
route justement pour la 12e fois en
quelques mois à radar fixe a été détruit
à l'explosif la cible était situé comme
toujours en région parisienne à l'entrée
cette fois de la commune de saint
gervais dans le val d'oise 10 actions
ont été revendiquées par la fraction
nationaliste armée révolutionnaire une
mystérieuse organisation sur laquelle
enquête le pôle antiterroriste de paris
lionel feierstein des films pas rick
miller
ça commence à faire beaucoup dans la
nuit de vendredi à samedi du côté de
saint gervais dans le val d'oise
un nouveau radar installé il ya moins de
trois semaines a sauté piégé à
l'explosif le 12e en moins d'un an
12 explosions toutes situées dans le
même secteur géographique au nord et à
l'ouest de paris
dix de ces attentats ont été revendiqués
par la fnar comprenez fraction
nationaliste armée révolutionnaire un
groupuscule aux idées plutôt confuse
dans un courrier du mois de mars il
revendiquait en vrac la suppression des
radars la baisse des impôts une relance
de la natalité mais aussi l'expulsion de
tous les clandestins
le discours est d'extrême droite mais le
logo rappelle le terrorisme allemand
d'extrême gauche celui de la bande à
baader
nous les considérons comme
potentiellement dangereuses comme je
vous le disais à partir du moment où des
gens commettent des attentats utilisent
des explosifs
ce sont déjà des gens dangereux pour
cesser leur action ces artificiers
demande toujours une rançon de quatre
millions d'euros
ce 12ème attentat n'a pas encore été
revendiqué en attendant l'enquêté a été
confiée aux policiers de
l'antiterrorisme
le rassemblement du teknival à crucey
villages est terminée selon les
organisateurs 25000 teufeurs c'est ainsi
qu'on appelle les fidèles de ces rendez
vous se sont retrouvés ce week-end sur
la base de l'otan en or elle
voir une rave party encadré et sous
surveillance quelques heures avant et en
marge de ce rassemblement une quinzaine
de personnes avaient été placées en
garde à vue pour trafic de stupéfiants
c'est officiel depuis aujourd'hui les
catholiques comptent en france un
nouveau lieu de pèlerinage il s'agit de
notre dame du lot dans les alpes c'est
la première fois qu'un tel événement
survient depuis la reconnaissance du
caractère surnaturel des apparitions de
lourdes en 1862 des milliers de fidèles
s'étaient déplacés ce matin pour
l'événement stéphane despinoy christophe
la rocca sur place notre dame du lot
attendait cela depuis plus de trois
siècles la reconnaissance officielle des
apparitions de la vierge marie à une
petite bergère
c'est désormais chose faite je reconnais
l'origine surnaturel des apparitions et
des faits vécus est relatée par benoîte
rencurel en conduisant son troupeau la
petite bergère aller à la rencontre de
celles qu'elle nommait l'appel dame
au total 600 apparition et selon
l'église un vrai dont elle disait à des
personnes
ce qu'ils avaient fait de la part de la
vierge marie en citant les personnes
voilà ce que vous avez fait vous avez
exploité la ferme de votre voisin où ils
les avaient volé sur les champs il faut
absolument vous convertissez votre vie
elle recevait temps en temps des claques
par un silence ce matin pour la
cérémonie 6000 fidèles sont montés au
sanctuaire voulait très heureux et on a
si c'est vraiment un événement
exceptionnel à l'opéra une fois dans
notre vie en procession cet après midi
ils sont actuellement 120 milles à
fréquenter notre dame du lot chaque
année et bientôt beaucoup plus c'est un
instant ça deviendra commercial du côté
du coeur sera selon l'évêque le
sanctuaire est d'autant plus important
qu'il se trouve dans un département
rural qui manque de prêtres
ce que je souhaitais c'est d'une part
que les fidèles qui viennent ici sachent
qu'ils peuvent vous venir en toute
confiance
et puis si ça permet de faire découvrir
ce lieu à d'autres personnes et bien je
m'en réjouis
ce serait prétentieux de dire on va
essayer de concurrencer lourds du
prochaine étape la petite bergère
benoîte pourraient être connus sainte la
béatification est déjà à l'étude au
vatican politique que faut-il penser du
service minimum d'accueil dans les
écoles un jour de grève et bien xavier
darcos lui n'en pense que du bien
le ministre de l'éducation après une
première expérience souhaite désormais
le généraliser ce qui n'est pas du goût
de tout le monde et notamment des
syndicats
réaction également à gauche jack lang
était l'invité aujourd'hui du dimanche
13 heures en écoute c'est de la frime
c'est surtout du camouflage du
camouflage des échecs que rencontre le
gouvernement dans le domaine de
l'éducation voilà s'il y a vraiment à
domaine dans lequel on doit mettre 5 sur
20 ou 4 sur 20 c'est pour l'école et
l'éducation
aujourd'hui le ministre a brisé les
programmes de l'école élémentaire qui
avait été unanimement approuvée par les
professeurs
le ministre fait disparaître des
milliers et des milliers de postes qui
vont mettre en danger la qualité de
notre lycée la vérité c'est que le rôle
d'un bon ministre
c'est d'éviter la grève nous sommes le 4
mai et dans deux jours cela fera
exactement un an que nicolas sarkozy est
devenu président de la république dans
nos différentes éditions nous aurons
l'occasion de dresser un bilan sur le
fond des réformes engagé voici ce soir
le bilan de la rupture sur la forme
douze premiers mois et un style de
présidence analyser en images par
michaël darmon samuel mèze et stéphane
guillon mai 2007 nicolas sarkozy ou le
président de toutes les ruptures le
sarko style est entrée à l'elysée
scénographie d'une nouvelle énergie
présidentielle affichant sans complexe
sa réussite et ses amitiés avec les
grands patrons
j'ai pas l'intention de me cacher j'ai
pas l'intention de tir j'ai pas
l'intention m'excuser la saga sarkozy
commence glamour gloire et politique au
sommet de l'état le nouveau président
est sur tous les fronts portable vissé à
l'oreille des solutions toutes faites
pour chaque problème
on se croirait presque dans la série 24
heures un super agent avec un super
agenda en une journée il passe de la
réforme des universités au problème du
darfour
il est le président tout info qui parle
à la place de tout le monde
merci monsieur le président
merci de me donner la parole aux parle
alors d'hyperprésidence pas hyper bien
critique l'opposition
peut-être les informations que je n'ai
pas il ya peut-être un premier ministre
aussi hyper pressé mais toujours
trouvant le temps de s'arrêter pour
grignoter comme dans cette épicerie
corse
des rois au président avec lui c'est
toujours pareil il touche il embrasse il
enserre comme pour se rassurer avec lui
tout marche à la secte enfin d'être en
première ligne
il prend un risque mais c'est son
honneur
dans le même temps nicolas sarkozy
essaye d'éviter une autre rupture
imposée celle là par cécilia
rien n'y fait le 18 octobre c'est
officiel jeudi noir pour le président
entre son divorce et les grèves
angué la console nicolas au sommet de
lisbonne
ouais je
m
crise personnelle et crise économique le
style sarkozy commence à déconcerter des
champions la visite du président kadhafi
à paris inaugure une série de recadrages
par rapport aux grandes déclarations de
campagne
c'est bien beau les leçons de droits de
l'homme et les postures entre le café le
flore et le zénith
j'ai dit au président kadhafi combien il
fallait continuer à progresser sur le
chemin des droits de l'homme
nouveau rebondissement deux mois après
son divorce nicolas sarkozy passe au
rayon célébrités politiques en révélant
son idylle avec l'ex mannequin chanteuse
carla bruni pour ses voeux à la presse
il prépare à un cocktail explosif de
volume de vie privée avec carla nous
avons décidé de ne pas mentir pour une
dose de pouvoir d'achat
s'agissant d'ailleurs du pouvoir d'achat
qu'est ce que vous attendez de -8 des
caisses qui sont déjà vides
coup de foudre présidentielle mais court
circuit dans l'opinion les français
jugent sévèrement le président alors au
salon de l'agriculture il y en a un qui
m'a prendre pour tout le monde
non je plaisante
sabine et kas passe comment
à l'elysée l'entourage de nicolas
sarkozy s'inquiète et le persuade de
changer de style
le président accepte à contrecoeur le
président dans l'imaginaire des français
ça reste une image gaullienne
pompidolienne mitterrandienne
chiraquienne et sarkozy nuit ne voulait
pas subir cet héritage et il a été
obligé finalement de s'adapter à ces
modèles antérieurs et à revenir à une
conception plus classique de la
présidence et je pense que nous avons
façon c'était pour lui vécu comme un
échec avec la nouvelle première dame
carla bruni sarkozy une nouvelle vie de
couple commence à l'elysée après des
mois de tumulte
c'est comme un rêve de visiter un v10
nous pourrons dire nous y étions entre
posture présidentielle et pose people
nicolas sarkozy tente désormais de
maîtriser son tempérament
sans doute moi même j'ai fait des
erreurs à partir du moment où il ya de
l'inquiétude de la mauvaise humeur il
faut la prendre pour ce qu'elle est et
moi je ne suis pas une personne a nié
les choses douze mois pour découvrir les
réalités du pouvoir mais entre sarko la
rupture et le président nicolas sarkozy
le bras de fer n'est peut-être pas
terminée l'emploi est une des priorités
du gouvernement et le préfet du rhône a
décidé de mettre l'accent sur l'emploi
des jeunes diplômés issus des quartiers
sensibles
il a fait le choix de contact et 600
entreprises de son département il ya
quelques mois un coup de pouce qui
semble déjà avoir porté ses fruits on
regarde le reportage de virginie fichés
et fils fils et son cap2 couturière ne
l'ouvré pas beaucoup de portes à 21 ans
kelly habite un quartier dit sensible
mais travaille depuis un mois et demi en
cdi dans ce magasin de sport sélectionné
par l'inpe elle a bénéficié de ce petit
coup de pouce supplémentaire pour
surmonter les préjugés d'en face bloqué
ce rôle pour faire montrer aux enfants
aux patrons que ils peuvent avoir
confiance en nous parce que pour eux et
voyez que nous sommes des jeunes qui
traînent dans la rue qu'on est dans la
vie dans des quartiers par le biais de
l'anpe le préfet a contacté 600
entreprises dès l'été dernier hervé
guyot l'employeur de kelly a joué le jeu
et constate une réelle évolution
je n'ai plus à faire une administration
quelconque j'ai à faire et nos
entreprises qu'ils fassent des jeunes
qui sélectionne de vrais candidats et
non pas nous envoyer des pile de cv pour
faire un peu du nombre comme on appelle
ça depuis le début de l'opération mille
cinq cent vingt jeunes diplômés de moins
de 30 ans ont été ciblés deux tiers ont
trouvé un emploi et le préfet ne compte
pas s'arrêter là
la prochaine étape concernera mille
jeunes non diplômés cette fois nous
sommes mais trop souvent partie
d'obligation de moyens
là nous sommes dans une logique de
projets et de résultats qui procède des
individus des parcours personnalisés et
qui vise simplement à la considération
de chacun fethi a décroché une
équivalence de son diplôme algérien de
management il ya deux ans depuis ils
galèrent déménageurs homme d'entretien
il n'a pas ménagé ses efforts mais se
sentait perdu
avant par exemple quand j'ai cherché du
travail c'était pour beaucoup plus
difficile c'était de cerner et de gagner
du temps avec le avec le principe est
par exemple mal orienté il m'a montré
les lignes directrices pour réussir
grâce à ce nouvel accompagnement
personnalisé fethi à décrocher un
entretien
dans quelques jours peut-être grossir
at-il les statistiques de la préfecture
qui vise à réduire de 40 % le chômage
des jeunes dans ces quartiers avant la
fin de l'année économie toujours où on
est on de la carte vitale
elle a dix ans déjà et la question à
l'époque était de savoir si les usagers
et professionnels de santé allaient
l'utiliser il a fallu un peu de temps
des débuts laborieux et quelques
réajustements pour éviter les fraudes
mais aujourd'hui un milliard de feuilles
de maladie électroniques sont traités
chaque année seulement chez les
professionnels certains rechignent
toujours à l'utiliser voix slaves et
qu'il junca et lionel langlais
il y a dix ans la carte vitale c'était
une expérience tester un peu partout en
france
aujourd'hui il existe près de 60
millions de ces petites cartes vertes et
leur utilisation s'est quasiment
généralisé pour ce pharmacien parisien
tout s'est passé très vite ça s'est très
vite fait un finalement c'était quelque
chose qui est qui qui allaient dans le
sens des besoins et puis ça s'est très
vite intégré on est passé aux prises à
sion quasi quasi totale de la capitale
auparavant pour se faire rembourser
après une visite chez le médecin ou un
achat chez le pharmacien il fallait
remplir des feuilles de soins puis les
envoyer à la sécurité sociale
des milliers de personnes traitées ces
dossiers grâce à la carte vitale la
télétransmission a éliminé la paperasse
les informations sont directement
envoyées à la sécu avec un milliard de
feuilles de soins électroniques par an
le taux d'utilisation de la carte vitale
plafonne pourtant à 70%
explication certains médecins comme
celui ci n'ont toujours pas adhéré au
système car les frais d'installation
sont à leur charge ordinateur modem
abonnement 4500 euros environ c'est un
peu injuste que ce soit aux médecins de
payer
ce système et de l'assumer et d'en être
responsable
c'est là le problème
dix ans après son lancement la carte
vitale a permis à la sécu de réaliser
des économies
son seul défaut les risques de fraude
pour y remédier les prochaines cartes
vitale porterons notre photo dans deux
ans 59 millions d'assurés devrait en
posséder une
le grand format de ce dimanche avec le
témoignage d'une française de 45 ans
habite en région parisienne qui a connu
un calvaire proche de celui qui vient
d'être révélée en autriche
lilia a été violée et maltraitée par son
père un homme qui a gardé une emprise
sur elle jusqu'à l'âge de 36 ans en la
terrorise en essais bouleversé par le
calvaire de la jeune autrichienne
qu'elle a décidé de se confier un
témoignage qui peut être douloureux pour
les plus jeunes téléspectateurs franck
gêne au zoo catherine juste c'est un
geste simple anodin passer ses mains
sous l'eau pourtant c'est un des petits
bonheurs quotidiens qui lui ont
longtemps été interdit dans le dos la
parade se laver pendant 28 ans lydia
gouardo a vécu l'enfer ici dans ce corps
de ferme vétustes séquestrée violée
quotidiennement par son père torturé par
sa belle-mère
le cauchemar commence un soir dans la
salle de bains elle a à peine huit ans
sipa voulait rentrer dans le bain parce
que quand vous mettez les pieds c'était
un petit peu chaud et elle a même
attrapé 20 victor pas frotter protéger
plus de huit mois d'hôpital pour des
brûlures au troisième degré à sa sortie
son père la retire de l'école pour dit
il mieux s'en occuper après ben ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'il a voulu faire
les pansements et la foule de choses
les violences ont lieu au deuxième étage
de cette bâtisse qu'elle n'a pas les
moyens de quitter
c'est là dans un réduit de quelques
mètres carrés qu'elle est attachée et
violée par celui qui est son père
légitime mais pas biologique
ça c'est toutes les conditions
ce que j'avais fait j'ai fait une cure
de l'âge et aux bêtises aussi fait
tourner la machine
et vous savez quoi avec l'acide
chlorhydrique temps qu'on avait pas mal
donc ont frayé pas continuer qu'après
quand vous vous réveillez ben vous êtes
plein ça c'est vrai c'est de la viande
puisque ont été tapées on est mais pour
nos cités normal les enfants site est
normal tout était normal
personne n'en sait rien quand c'était
normal de ces viols répétés naissent six
enfants
à chaque fois le vieux comme elle
l'appelle assistent à ces accouchements
sacha maladie comme ça et le père et la
vie est si élevé il est bien à côté de
moi il a dit comme ça c'est moi le père
c'est moi qui vais lui donner à manger à
cet enfant cimatti rhinoise quoi et ça
s'est passé pour sa part réagi la fed
accouchement tout est là donne le petit
inventaire vous ai pas demandé si vous
avez besoin d aide non pendant toutes
ces années
les autorités ne s'aperçoive de rien
pourtant lydia gouardo fugue jusqu'à
huit fois par mois à chaque fois les
services sociaux la renvoie chez elle
les gendarmes enquêtent sans rien décelé
les voisins eux portent plainte mais
pour nuisances sonores l'enfant crier
trop fort observons ce cadre chacun chez
soi et c'est tout et rien d'autre en
raymond gouardo décède d'une crise
cardiaque il ne sera jamais jugé
l'ex belle mère est quant à elle
condamné pour non dénonciation de crimes
et agressions sexuelles sur mineurs
quatre ans de prison avec sursis
une immense déception pour lydia gouardo
mais il ya quelques jours elle découvre
une histoire proche de la sienne
survenus en autriche et qui suscite chez
elle en espoirs
j'aimerais bien voir monsieur là qui a
fait sa fille lui poser la question
pourquoi il a fait ça sa fille comme ça
j'aurai la réponse peut-être mon père
est ce que vous aimeriez rencontrer
cette d'armes en autriche
maintenant je suis pas tout seul faut
dire on va était à deux mètres ce
retraité lui expliquer aussi comment
vivre avec l'image du tortionnaire
quand je vois mes enfants je vois le
vieux parce qu'ils ont tous à six le
plus grand est le caractère du vieux g
ils ont tous voulu mais quand même ah
ben non
jeudi ils savent quand il est mort j'ai
envie de découvrir plein de trucs parce
qu'au départ je n'osais pas sortir
mais quand je suis sorti c'était plus la
peine la même la halle en ce moment j'ai
de la chance de m'en voyez vous ce
chiffre c'est sûr partie allez bonne
visite et bien voilà un peu cher c'est
vrai mais bon c'est pas grave et beau
navire dans quinze jours elle publiera
un livre sur son histoire
elle rêve aussi de changer de nom d'un
beau mariage avec le papa de ses deux
derniers enfants de vacances au bord de
la mer en famille
après tout ce qu'elle a vécu elle ne
craint plus les petits chocs de la vie
l'insouciance d'une adolescence qui
commence à l'âge de 45 ans
voilà en bref est une nouvelle étape
dans la sphère florence cassez cette
française condamnée au mexique à 96 ans
de prison ses parents réclamé hier je
vous le disais une intervention du chef
de l'état on n'a pas aujourd'hui qu'ils
seront reçus mercredi à l'elysée
dans l'actualité à l'étranger à un
rendez vous attendu et réclamer cette
fois également
mais pour quel résultat des discussions
entre deux émissaires du dalaï lama et
des responsables chinois ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui à shenzhen le thème de ces
entretiens la crise au tibet bien sûr
selon l'agencé chine nouvelle
les participants se seraient mis
d'accord pour poursuivre six rencontres
aucune date n'a été en revanche fixée
pour le moment mardi les primaires
reprenne aux états unis pour les deux
candidats démocrates ce sera au tour de
l'hymne diana et de la caroline du nord
de tenter de départager barack obama et
hillary clinton
mais attention ne pas trop se focaliser
sur ce duel on on aurait tendance à
oublier l'autre candidat côté
républicain mais alors que fait john
mccain réponse aux états unis
alain de chalvron qu'il est doux d'être
candidat quand ses adversaires s'entre
déchirer qu'on n'a plus qu'à ramasser
les marchés alors qu'il arrivait obama
passe dix huit heures par jour en
campagne à se dénigrer la l'autre john
mackey nuit poursuit son tour du pays à
train de sénateur accompagné de son
épouse aussi blonde que silencieuse pour
répéter et répéter encore son message je
suis fier d'être un républicain
conservateur comme au premier jour
john mccain regarde l'amérique au fond
des yeux et du fond du microscope
il la trouve vachement fasciné it est
une fascinante
il ne s'en lasse pas de cette amérique
qui crée tient vente mais qui souffre
aussi beaucoup de nos compatriotes se
demandent comment ils vont faire pour
garder leur maison pour se payer une
assurance santé
mais mes amis beaucoup d'américains
passe à l'intérieur problème si elle
souffre l'amérique c'est tout de même un
peu à cause de georges bush républicains
comme lui d'ailleurs les démocrates
l'appel mac bouche et ça n'est pas
seulement un sport difficile d'incarner
à la fois l'héritage et la rupture sur
ce point
mccain est fasciné par l'exemple sarkozy
j'adore votre président s'il ya un
domaine où mccain ne prend pas ses
distances c'est bien l'irak la guerre
jusqu'à la victoire c'est son mot
d'ordre
il s'est payé un petit voyage à bagdad
au milieu des boys qui aurait été un
plein succès s'il ne s'était terminée
sur une gaffe monumentale où le candidat
s'est emmêlé les pinceaux entre chiites
et sunnites iran ray al qaïda à monsieur
rizzoli je voulais dire que les iraniens
entraîne des élections des miss cheat et
nomade il n'en a pas fallu plus pour que
les médias pointent à nouveau son âge 71
ans son handicap principal john mchale
le genre de gars qui décroche la
télécommande de la télé lorsque le
téléphone sonne à cela john mccain
répond tout simplement en se tournant
vers sa mère 95 ans sous-entendu j'ai de
bons gènes
la chaleur ne fait pas bon ménage avec
les ordures ménagères à annappes et la
population est désormais au bord de la
crise de nerfs la ville du sud de
l'italie entre dans une période plus
estivale elle n'a toujours pas résolu
son problème de déchets et certains vous
allez le voir n'hésite pas à incendier
les amas de détritus nous envoyés
spéciaux fils misseria c'est clara au
score le feu en dernier recours
c'est ainsi qu'à naples les habitants se
débarrasse des ordures qui s'amoncellent
encore dans leur rue
avec le retour de la chaleur les odeurs
sont devenues insupportables
hier une trentaine de feux de poubelles
ont été signalés dégageant des fumées
toxiques
c'est pire que bagdadi si on ne s'en
sortira pas pourtant depuis quelques
mois dans la campagne autour de naples
plusieurs sites de stockage provisoire
reçoivent tous les jours des centaines
de tonnes d'ordures problème ils seront
bientôt saturent
pour les incinérer on les envoie même en
allemagne 50 trains sont partis de
naples pour l'abc qu un périple de 1600
km à naples la saison touristique s'est
ouverte dans la morosité
faute de clients ce célèbre hôtel a dû
fermer ses portes dans ce grand
restaurant les tables reste souvent
vides
nous avons une chute de 70 % de notre
clientèle certaines agences nous ont
appelés pour annuler en disant naples
c'est fini un centre ville relativement
propre des banlieues encore jonchée de
sacs poubelles c'est le visage de naples
aujourd'hui une situation que l'union
européenne accepte pas elle menace de
saisir la cour européenne de justice
pour dénoncer l'inefficacité de
l'administration italienne sergio
berlusconi le nouveau chef du
gouvernement a annoncé qu'il tiendra son
premier conseil des ministres à naples
et qu'il fera du règlement de la crise
des déchets
sa priorité numéro un le sport et le
football qui de paris toulouse ou lens
rejoindra la ligue 2 l'an prochain c'est
apparemment entre ces trois grands clubs
que les choses devraient se se jouait
pour le dernier fauteuil maudit un
suspense et les questions quelles
seraient les conséquences pour un club
par exemple comme le paris saint-germain
les joueurs les sponsors le public
début de réponse avec christophe tortora
l'égalisation toulousaine hier soir à la
dernière minute presque psg 18e au
classement relégable à deux journées de
la fin
une descente serait une catastrophe
sportive mais également un désastre
financier
le psg est le troisième plus gros budget
de ligue 1 avec 70 millions d'euros
cette année le club verrait son budget
divisé par trois en ligue 2 le budget ne
serait plus que de 20 millions d'euros
le psg était l'une des équipes les plus
diffusés cette année les droits télé fa
serait de 28 millions d'euros versés à
six millions d'euros en ligue 2 une
éventuelle relégation auront aussi des
conséquences sur l'effectif actuellement
le psg compte dans ses rangs cinq des
plus gros salaires du championnat de
france
pauleta deuxième et rothen 5e gagne plus
de 4 millions d'euros par an une baisse
automatique de 20% du salaire des
joueurs est prévue en cas de descente
généralement ils préfèrent quitter le
navire à ce jour
en l2 les plus gros salaires sont de
l'ordre de 40 mille euros brut par mois
pour ce championnat
je vois difficilement des joueurs à 100
ou 200 millions euros par mois même avec
20 % moins l'année prochaine sous le
maillot du psg parce que le budget ne
pourra pas suivre en ligue 2 les
tumultueux supporters s'ils viennent
verront leur place deux fois moins cher
les sponsors vont s'interroger pas
enchanté d'être associée une équipe qui
perd seule la mairie de paris a assuré
le club de sa fidélité
paradoxe pari est d'ores et déjà assuré
de jouer la coupe de l'uefa l'an
prochain grâce à sa victoire en coupe de
la ligue
il reste deux matches aux clubs pour
tenter de rester en ligue 1
parmi l'élite est à noter les résultats
de cette fin d'après midi saint-etienne
et lille ont fait match nul en fin de
journée 0 0
et puis ce soir le dauphin de lyon
bordeaux se déplace à marseille un match
au sommet entre le deuxième et le
troisième de ligue 1
le cinéma avec tu peux garder un secret
le dernier film d'alexandre arcady avec
juliette arnaud et pierre arditi une
comédie romantique ou comment un
mensonge insignifiant peut se
transformer en véritable vaudeville
pascal deschamps et marie cros mais pas
du tout regardé un secret voilà j'ai su
que j aurais été très discrète
parce que l'homme que j'aime en fait
c'est notre patron pour cacher son
désert sentimental delphine invente un
gros mensonge et bien sûr le secret va
faire le tour de sa boîte
une situation délicate dont les deux
amis de toujours vont tenter de
l'attirer
le mieux étant vraiment amoureux de moi
trois bonnes copines et leurs histoires
de mecs c'est ce qui a fait le succès de
ces drôles de dames dans leur spectacle
arrête de pleurer pénélope avec lequel
elles sont toujours en tournée cinq cent
mille spectateurs en quatre ans et
pourtant quand on leur a enfin proposé
un film elle n'y croyait pas d'où l'idée
d'avoir la campagne et nous avons
prélevé en cette vie ouais bien sûr mais
où la caméra qu'est ce qui se passe on
n'y a pas cru une seule seconde qu'on
est resté de marbre vous attendu le
scénario vous dont kiel s'est dit ok
donc elle se la pètent la liaison un
jour à grosse tête comme ça c'était
vraiment sa maîtresse une pas mission
impossible je crois chez gagosian au
final à ce que le prince le prince c'est
pierre arditi l'acteur fétiche d'alain
resnais au répertoire théâtral plutôt
sérieux découvrez ici un style plus
débridé la pression de voir les pieds
nickelés
alors donc ça va beaucoup s'amuser quoi
parce qu'elles sont elles ont raison
goût de charme en même temps elles sont
complètement bordello ce bon et c'est ce
qui fait leur charme et leur lors
comment dire leur identité il ya plein
de gens intelligents
alors là je dis bravo
je donne ma lettre de démission le
démissionner parce que cette mode c'est
pas une faute professionnelle ce défi
les pénélopes bing c'est au cinéma qu
elles ont pris goût puisque deux halls
de gare en aéroport et les écrivent leur
phrasé spectacle pour le grand écran
et comme chaque dimanche voici
maintenant le classement des films au
premier jour de leur sortie cette
semaine en tête ce n'est pas vraiment
une surprise
iron man le super héros américains qui
rêvent d'une bande dessinée en deuxième
position le beau film de jean becker
deux jours à tuer avec albert dupontel
ensuite autre film français le grand
alibi de pascal bonitzer adaptation d'un
roman d'agatha christie enfin 15 ans et
demi avec entre autres daniel auteuil on
prend la direction de venise maintenant
et sa célèbre place saint-marc qui n'est
plus vraiment la même depuis quelques
heures ainsi nourrir les pigeons est
désormais devenu formellement interdit
sous peine d'amendés décision appliquée
ou pas et bien on voit cela avec le
reportage en italie de philippe
visseyrias et clara bosco dernier festin
avant fermeture définitive sur la place
saint marc les vendeurs de graines en
colère ont organisé une petite
manifestation une distribution gratuite
pour protester contre la décision de la
mairie qui les met au chômage
nous voulons rester ici et continuer à
travailler pour faire vivre la culture
de venise ils sont en train de tuer
venir ici les pigeons sont comme les
gondoles ils font partie du décor
place saint marc des générations de
touristes se sont fait photographier en
train de nourrir les charmants volatiles
plutôt envahissant et peu farouches
tellement gavés de graines qu'il se
laisse attraper sans résistance
désormais les nourrir coûte cher 50
euros damende entre les pour et les
contre
le débat fait rage non la venue pour ça
pour voir les pigeons plus
c'est triste les pigeons il faut tous
ces mots fait mouche attaques commencent
à éclater
c'est comme si vous enlevez la tour
eiffel à paris et apprend la rive les
bijoux depuis dix ans la place
saint-marc et est le dernier refuge des
pigeons de venise le seul endroit de la
ville où l'on avait encore le droit de
les nourrir
ils s'y sont tellement multiplier que
pour les vénitiens sont était devenue
invivable
ici c'est devenu un poulailler ou plutôt
un pigeonnier
on marche littéralement sur les fientes
de pigeons vous pouvez voir sur les
monuments la corrosion des marbres
chaque contribuable vénitien dépenses
par an 275 euros pour nettoyer et
réparer les monuments de la ville
endommagées par les fientes de pigeons
entre tradition touristique et respect
d'un patrimoine unique la sérénissime a
choisi même si c'est impopulaire
ces policiers municipaux en savent
quelque chose après avoir essayé de
dissuader les vendeurs de graines
il bat en retraite sous les railleries
avons terminé journal je vous rappelle
l'une des informations du jour ce
cyclone qui a touché la birmanie
le bilan est lourd plus de 350 morts la
ville de rangoun a été touchée
nombreuses habitations dévastées
près de cent mille personnes seraient
déjà pour le moment sans abri voilà pour
l'essentiel de l'information de cette
fin de week-end merci à vous d'avoir
suivi ce journal la météo c'est avec
isabelle martinez puis du cinéma avec
sandra bullock est un film de barbet
schroeder calculs meurtriers demain 13h
élise lucet à 20h david pujadas
je vous souhaite un très bon dimanche
soir
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr